they don't mess about in Yorkshire Roley
SFX specialized in explosive effects and
you might know their work from peaky
blinders more and more movies rely on
visual effects to create impressive
explosions but did you know companies
like this one use all kinds of inventive
methods to give a reference for CG as
well as for actors and stunt performers
to react to that we have come all the
way up to Yorkshire to blow some stuff
up and have a look at the value of
practical effect and I'm going to try
and make my own version of the action
star facing away from explosion sequence
today we're going to be setting off some
bullet hits and explosive effects all in
this yard just outside of Leeds showing
us around is dad Ian Rowley and his son
Rob when bullets hit a wall or any
surface they can fragment and shoot up
dust and debris this is created by a
series of hidden dust heads these are
the bags full of dust and with a small
marooning it every one has its own
individual radio receiver so the radio
receivers up there in this particular
case that's the rig so that cable goes
back up there like that and over the
wall so when that's fired up blow the
bits out it represents the bullet
hitting the stonework so there's a very
simple hit hit and run is gonna be the
benefit of using a squib here it's that
the actor can stand close about a foot
away in a scene with other live action
it's safe to be that close to it well
yeah it's just a shockwave there's
energy shockwave yeah the only debris
that's in it and bits of cardboard an
explosive device like a hand grenade has
got a steel casing around it and the
steel fragments and the steel is what
causes all the damage but what about
fire balls of course you could do a fire
explosion purely in CG which wouldn't
damage a building
but this method doesn't allow the stunt
actors to react to a series of explosive
charges the production could use a scale
model of the set and do a smaller
explosion on that but unless your budget
is Star Wars level you can't
convincingly situated in frame roll es
effects uses a propane gas system that
actually protects buildings with a
benefit of being able to film the shot
live with real actors and vehicles you
can see it at work here in the season
two opener of peaky blinders it's a
vessel we can fill with propane
something flammable or something you
know like nitrogen to give either a
fireball or a big blast of air so a
hopper with dust you know fire that over
some video you know we can build this
into a shop window and you know a big
fireball out of it they're really
versatile bits of equipment we have
various sizes of them one of these will
give you an fireballs about sort of 9 10
meters so it's when you don't need
structures effectively being compromised
yeah so it's like it's like a giant
shotgun where where we point it is where
it goes you might also see this kind of
technique for bomb blasts in TV and
movies with a container hidden out of
sight under the stage flash porch gives
us a bright white point of ignition
there's some smoke with it this is
called a robot a shower of very hot
sparks again to guarantee ignition and
so this would normally be kind of dug
under the ground but have been buried
yeah you know mortars out of the ground
or stood around the back of the vehicle
you know and piped in through the floor
this particular method makes that a lot
softer so we're blowing it into this
tank where it can okay going live and
firing in 3 2 1
of course if you can't get access to
Bucky and palates to blow it up on
camera you're going to use VFX but on a
set or old building this is a system
that quickly set up and controlled a
similar technique is using a woofer
which releases the gas slower and comes
in varying sizes these guys might make
this look easy but setting up this kind
of equipment takes years of training and
skill the company goes all the way back
to 1946 I heard the only effects company
ever to get anywhere near it with
pyrotechnics [ __ ] pants the Queen's
crew thrilled with that burning post
office so we loaded the silo blasters
into the post office is the only offense
I've ever done with the suits on time to
show the impact of an explosion on the
ground the team fills containers such as
this bomb tank with rubble or soil I put
a big lifting charge in the bottom maybe
some petrol on top you know fill it with
soil the shape of this means it goes
upwards and not left and right wall
movies and TV shows will use something
like this in a well-timed action
sequence such as stunt performers being
thrown into the air by impact for the
biggest blasts Productions will use
gallons of kerosene and powder
explosives this technique allows for the
shot to be filmed live with the
performers with the explosions enhanced
afterwards in CG take this shot from The
Dark Knight Rises where charges
compacted with dirt were fired from the
ground of Heinz Field while stuntman
sprinted away the crumbling field under
foot was added in post-production they
have a stuntman run by he'd hit a tram
pair like a little trampoline you know
as he jumps on it and can you see him
leave that's your cue to fire it and you
know he's travelling on the back of that
it's all about timing timing and cues
and that can be quite tricky in a
situation where you've got a lot of
extras a lot of multiple
things happening multiple queues timing
is everything in this industry for the
biggest explosion ever created on a set
the destruction of Blofeld's moroccan
comm center
inspector sfx supervisor chris kobold
used two thousand two hundred and twenty
four gallons of kerosene and seventy two
pounds of powder explosives timed to
detonate in the middle of a line of
dialogue this is why sfx teams will
always go through dry rehearsals of a
stunt so when it looks good it only
needs a small amount of cg alteration
afterwards the way an explosion is shot
can change everything for huge nuclear
explosions filming a wide-angle shot can
expose the magnitude of the explosion by
capturing the vast space around it this
is normally done in VFX mimicking and
irreparable destruction other movies
choose to do full coverage and enhance
it later in CG such as this truck
explosion in Mad Max fury road the
effect which use 96 detonators and 1360
litres of fuel was extremely visceral
and realistic as was an SFX captured
from different angles characters and
foreground layers were added in
afterwards in CG occasionally though the
stature of the main character will be
enhanced by using a short focal length
on an actor to make the explosion look
more dramatic these are the kind of
slow-motion big shots used all the time
in action movies so that's what we're
gonna have a go out today piece of cake
okay I'm gonna I will see when you hit
this mark okay no I was gonna keep going
no sting slow-mo on this right
here's the shot from different angles
full-coverage and the more stylized
action shot which makes the explosion
look a lot bigger than it is this could
also be enhanced in CG and graded I try
to give the Zoolander phase but I think
I just I just let me out breath oh it's
still burning
so did I manage to pull off the shot the
explosion looks much bigger behind me at
this angle but I think you really have
to be walking to look as cool as the
rock whether you almost say like the
practical way is always the best way
you've got to have foundation there
definitely work alongside I mean there
was things the effects yeah started to
become a thing but they always want a
practical element you know to give the
actors something to respond to you know
the way light interacts with with it
maybe they can't afford or haven't got
the time to do you know 100 hits around
a room maybe we just do 20 physical ones
well I doubt I'm gonna be getting that
stunt recruitment phone call anytime
soon it was fascinating to see the
intricate practical methods used to
recreate movie explosions
[Music]
you